allergique aux mathématiques ne fuyait
pas c'est derviches sondés croppi la
base du travail de gouvernance
le plasticien français on fait de l'art
de l'art numérique
c'est une passion c'est j'ai commencé
sans même imaginer que j'étais dans une
démarche artistique
vous avez vraiment à coeur une recherche
le désir de découvrir ou de mener ce
matériau
la fascination pour les couvre depuis
l'enfance donc je vois de l'infini dans
les caussinus les simus les logarithmes
et les exponentielle et j'ai commencé
vraiment très tout a commencé à combiner
ces ce matériau des oeuvres infini à la
vie autonome
hugo verlinde de créer des codes
permettant de développer des univers
propre comme ceux lotus réalisé en lycra
exposé pour la première fois
e
c'est un rêve c'est un rêve le point de
départ du lotus c'est je me suis vu dans
une pièce un peu comme ici une grande
pièce que beaucoup d'espacé de hauteur
et en me baladant j'étais face à un
énorme pétales qui avec laquelle
exactement donc cette forme qu'on voit
là et j'en faisais le tour et je
découvrais une projection sur sur un
métal jeux de lumière les sensations des
espaces infinis hugo verlinde vous
entraîne dans un voyage numérique